hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my flash finale video so many
awesome things happen and even even
though there are a lot of big questions
left by the cliffhanger the producers
have done some interviews so we do have
some big answers just careful for
spoilers from the episode I'm going to
start with the really big stuff first
like the really big questions so here we
go
season 2 going to rely heavily on time
travel as a plot device they said you
know at the end of the episode they have
that promo where they said we have an
exciting new way to introduce villains
that's going to be the wormhole think
about it this way in season 1 they had a
particle accelerator explosion created
all those metahumans you know it was a
huge disaster that gave rise to all
these new characters season 2 now has
this disaster to give rise to a bunch of
new characters the confirmed ones that
we know about right now are dr. alchemy
and mirror master they had they haven't
confirmed any other villains yet Gorilla
Grodd on a lot of the favorites from
season 1 they'll totally be back I mean
we saw Captain cold in the episode we
even saw Hawkgirl so here we go I was
gonna do top 10 moments because so much
happened in this episode starting with
number 10 the reverse flash actually
refuses to tell Barry what happened
between them to start off their feud I
was kind of bummed when he didn't
explain it but that just means that they
can leave it for future episode we can
find out at some other time the point of
the whole conversation was really
explaining why he killed Nora Allen it
was because he thought that was the way
to get rid of Barry Allen for good
because he couldn't beat him in a
one-on-one fight kill his younger self
so erase him from existence but in doing
so it led to ripple effects that left
him unable to access the Speed Force in
the comic books elbahr Thawne becomes
the reverse flash because he finds a
Barry Allen time capsule with like Barry
Allen's costume in his flash ring in it
in reverse engineers his flash powers
that's why he's called the reverse flash
so if the Barry Allen flash never
existed the reverse flash would have
never gained powers Martin Stein did a
good job of explaining the negative
effects of time travel you know like
erasing all the things that had happened
the good things and the bad things I
love the bargain that he makes you
opened the wormhole so that I can get
home but that wormhole will also allow
you to go back and save your mother and
yes if he had say to his mother it
probably would have wiped everything
from existence it would have gone
darkest timeline moving on to number 9
Ronnie proposes to Caitlin snow they've
had a difficult job selling that
romance this year because Ronnie just
hasn't been around Caitlin's been
talking about him in past tense it's not
like watching two characters fall in
love on screen over the course of the
season so hats off to danielle Panabaker
and robbie milk for selling it to us i
thought i thought they did a good job
Robbie Amell is always a lot of fun you
know hopefully he'll be back at least
for the first half of season to remember
what Caitlin said though the opportunity
to go back and see someone you love
she's an incredibly smart person but you
can see in her head she's ignoring the
negative consequences of time travel
speaking of which when Barry was seeing
the past present and future we actually
saw a danielle Panabaker in frozen
cosplay just put a bookmark on that
that's going to take a little more
explaining in my list here moving out to
number 8 Barry's dad tells him not to
save their mother most of the people
were telling Barry to do what he thought
was right
you know take care of yourself you take
care of everyone else so much Barry's
dad was one of the few people who was
like you cannot do this even if it means
saving your mother's life think of what
it might cost more than any other
character I feel like John Wesley Shipp
has been like the moral center of the
show
the talk he had with Irish was really
funny too though I never thought of
myself as a hyphenate er maybe that's a
20/20 thing movie number 7 the
reverse-flash explains time travel how
funny is it that this time travel plan
is how the particle accelerator is
supposed to work it does function as a
regular particle accelerator but the
reverse-flash built it with this in mind
knowing that this is what it would be
used for Barry Allen running fast enough
in one direction in a hydrogen particle
moving in the opposite direction I
actually kind of thought that the
reverse flash was going to be that other
particle running in the opposite
direction like they would both run in
opposite directions until they collided
at SuperSpeed Cisco asking all the time
machine questions are so funny tell me
how do you fit that suit in your ring
wait no I don't want to know well I kind
of do moving on to number six the
reverse-flash reveals that cisco is a
metahuman this is one of the biggest
surprises of the episode and I think one
of the most important things going into
season two originally I thought that
Cisco being you know very tech based
person would just make his own tech he'd
become vibe that way the way they're
explaining it on the show is just a
slight change from the comics they're
actually they're making Cisco's ability
that much more powerful
the reverse-flash said that he is
sensitive to the vibrations of the
universe
meaning the Cisco can probably sense
when timelines have changed I think that
they're going to use that as a plot
device in season 2 if the storyline is
going to rely heavily on time travel
then it would make sense to have a
character that could sense when
characters are coming from other times
that actually that ties in with that Jay
Garrick helmet if you remember it just
flew right out of the wormhole meaning
that it came from an alternate timeline
a la multiverse I also think that might
be the backdoor to killer frost to
Caitlin snow killer frost she won't be
our version of Caitlin that we've seen
this season she'll be from an alternate
timeline I know it's gonna get really
confusing you know time travel who knows
what but what I think is gonna happen is
is we'll have like our prime timeline
with the characters that we've come to
know you know Eddie has died the
reverse-flash is gone but you'll have
other characters spilling in from other
timelines a great and honourable destiny
awaits you I hope that you remember that
that was given to you out of love such a
creepy relationship between the
reverse-flash and Cisco creepy
father-son thing going on although it
was so great when he said oh no I'm not
sorry for killing you I'm sure had a
great reason for that like yeah eobard
thawne still a huge dick Tom Cavanagh
definitely the MVP actor from this
season I think that's why they cast him
in the role just because he's playing so
many different characters at the same
time like you have original Harrison
wells you have a bard Thawne then you
have kind of like a combination of the
two and then next season we'll have a
new version of Harrison wells movie
answer number five Martin Stein explains
Eddie thawne's role in all this just
like he says this entire season he's
been the biggest wild card his destiny
is not tied to the destiny of the
reverse-flash because he's the
originator of the bloodline even though
we have multiverse we have alternate
timelines all kinds of crazy time-travel
going on next season the way the
producers talked about Eddie's suicide
made it sound like it was going to stick
at least through the first half of
season 2 they just said that the group
would be trying to process Eddie's death
and learning how to go forward so it
sounds like Rick cos net the actor won't
be coming back to the show in like a big
way until maybe a ways in the future
that doesn't mean he won't ever come
back we could see him like the back half
of the season the first half of season 2
is mostly
to be building up to the legends of
tomorrow spinoff we even saw like
whenever he buried was time-traveling
and was saying past present future in
addition to caitlin snow he also saw you
know the flash museum which is like a
huge WTF and he saw the legends of
tomorrow team up there was like a scene
from the legends of tomorrow trailer
so it's not that the first half of
season 2 is mostly going to deal with
the fallout from this wormhole alternate
timelines big catastrophe it will set
the stage for why this legends of
tomorrow spin-off is necessary even
though Rick has net Candice Patton great
actors I loved their performance I just
I didn't buy their relationship I was in
a big fan of them together but didn't
you think that when he was talking about
the failed date with the dancer that
that was the person he was intended to
marry and start the thawne line screw
the future that'd be a good motto for
like the first half of season 2 like a
good subtitle on to number 4 Caitlin and
Ronnie's wedding who knew that Martin
Stein world renowned scientist was also
a Jewish rabbi you learn new comic book
facts every day when I saw that this
came like really late in the episode I
was wondering how they were gonna leave
it I guess that they'll be married well
into the first half of season 2 if
Ronnie was going to die in like some big
way they they probably would have killed
him before the end of the episode so by
all accounts when episode 1 picks up
they will still be together everything
will be fine this raises a whole lot of
questions about what's happening with
firestorm in season 2 and with the
spin-off series because if Martin Stein
is still firestorm on legends of
tomorrow why is it Robbie Amell also on
that series that could also be an
alternate timeline multiverse thing on
to number 3 Barry goes back in time but
does not save his mother just taking a
look at the scene Barry goes back but
future buried the one that saved young
Barry tells him to stop like he's like
no don't do this
don't save our mother doesn't that give
you the sense that maybe he's tried that
before
like maybe future Barry understands what
will be changed like what will be lost
if his mother does survive maybe this is
all happened before and for those of you
wondering where that future Barry went
he was erased from existence the minute
Nora Allen died it was really cry worthy
moment I you know I loved that final
scene they had together you look just
like my father I got a second chance to
tell you that I'm okay me and dad were
okay I love you it's relatively close
- the flashpoint paradox storyline where
he goes back in time to try and save his
mother and finds out that if he does
that it leads to darkest timeline so he
has to let her die moving it's number
two the reverse flash teases rip hunter
alternate universes rip hunter would be
impressed he built the first one of
these that's just a big tease for the
spin-off series rip hunter is part of
the time masters so I'm wondering if a
Bart Thawne is also tied to that
organization they didn't really answer
that question the reason I think he said
that the Jay Garrick helmet was his cue
to leave is because he sensed the time
was starting to spill in on itself and
that if he stayed longer then it might
affect his timeline and finally my
number one WTF moment giant time vortex
opens up over the earth it's threatening
to destroy everything isn't it
interesting that Martin Stein said that
even after it ate the earth he said that
the vortex would still be there it seems
like it's a black hole but it's also a
gateway between universes between
timelines really I know it's lamda black
just as Barry ran up into it
but I think that T's is is that you know
he's coming back just fine in season 2
but probably not after seeing a whole
bunch of other really trippy stuff he'll
probably be able to run fast enough to
close it but not before a bunch of other
things spill out into their timeline
that's where I think the new villains
the new and interesting villains are
coming from that Andrew Kreisberg and
Greg Berlanti teased so you get new
villains from the past present and
future
that's where you get Jay Garrick that's
where you get mirror master dr. alchemy
even killer frost in Cisco is the key to
sensing where they came from like okay
this person is not from our timeline as
for Tom Cavanagh coming back as Harrison
wells in season two because of what Eddy
did a Bart Thawne never existed to go
back in time and kill Harrison wells
so Harrison wells never died here's my
big question for you guys you know if
they're doing time-travel alternate
timelines universes in season two who
else do you want to see them bring on
the show as cool as the multiverses I
just I feel like it's a really cool
opportunity to see other versions of the
characters fight each other like you
have Caitlin snow versus team flash but
it's not our Caitlin it's like alternate
time line killer frost Caitlyn and what
if Barry also kind of skips around the
multiverse a little bit like what if we
get to see the flash Museum that'd be
amazing feel free to make as many Doctor
Who jokes as you want I'm just like I'm
so happy with the way they did this
season of all the comic book shows on on
TV I feel like the flash had the
strongest narrative and some of the
strongest characters too I think they
owe a lot of that success to the amount
of time they've spent working on arrow
like they're slowly perfecting this
comic book model but it took them a
couple years on arrow to kind of figure
out how to hit that I'm going to do a
season two predictions video in a couple
days so be sure to subscribe to get that
but just right off the bat they are
going to be weaving in a lot of
crossovers with legends of tomorrow and
arrow like all these three shows they're
building this CW comic book universe
like a monthly comic book event you know
you have like convergence with its
spin-off titles everyone would just
bounce back and forth that's why there's
a lot of hope that Supergirl could
crossover in season 2 but they said they
said no Supergirl crossovers in season 1
have been planned but some really fun
Easter eggs that I haven't mentioned
already Douglas Adams Hitchhiker's Guide
Andrew Kreisberg said that he felt like
Cisco would be a big Douglas Adam fan so
that's why he gave him the joke about so
long thanks for all the fishes that's
this right out of hitchhikers guide and
just to run down the list of all the
things that Barry saw when he was
time-traveling Kalyn snow killer frost
the flash Museum which is obviously from
the future we see Barry Allen in jail
just confirming we're going to see
alternate versions of the flash more to
that - they said that they were bringing
other speedsters on so that means like
Jay Garrick Wally West all that stuff
and then the moment from legends of
tomorrow the legends of tomorrow trailer
of course we saw Hawkgirl and Captain
cold in the spin-off series who knows
when they'll show up again hopefully
it'll be like episode 1 because you
kinda have to build up to that team-up
moment on the rooftop in the legends of
tomorrow trailer that looks like it's
going to come sometime around the
midseason finale of season 2 legends of
tomorrow is supposed to premiere in
January
whenever flash and arrow come back so
obviously you have to hit that moment
before episode 1 so I'm going to be
doing a whole bunch of flash legends of
tomorrow arrow Supergirl bonus videos
this summer is anything special you guys
want to see first just be sure to leave
your requests in the comments below in
the meantime
you can click here to catch up on all my
flash videos and you can click here for
my agents of shield season 3 predictions
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you